[Música]
eu adoro cinema
agora como foi de tudo tem a ver com o
som imagem e tecnologia todas essas
coisas e mais ou menos há cerca de dez
anos mais coisa menos coisa eu percebi
que dos filmes todos os efeitos
especiais que vi no cinema a amil
participações especiais dos mais
interessantes utilizaram uma técnica
chamada de temas práticos o que são os
sistemas de partículas não fui lá é uma
técnica utilizada em computação gráfica
em que se cria milhares ou até mesmo
milhões pequenos pontos e depois todos
estes pontos juntos criam a ilusão de
coisas como foi o fumo um bom tempo
estado da bahia chuva após fada todas
essas coisas por exemplo
imaginem é esta explosão que ia passar
em qualquer filme 'os na realidade desta
técnica ou seja cada grão do pó que
vocês ganham livre do fumo
tudo isto são milhares ou milhões pontue
na altura quando eu percebi isto é como
eu sempre tive uma paixão muito grande
pela área do som pensei não significa
cantar tics nós utilizássemos isso para
criar som de milhares de sons de forma
fantástica uma ideia como aquelas 500
mil idéias que nós temos ao longo da
vida e não fazendo nada para se
concretizaram e o tempo foi passando
quatro anos a coisa eu tinha acabado o
doutoramento e ainda ninguém queria
pegar o primeiro desta ideia de utilizar
sistemas partículas som e com chrome
informatics ou porque esta casa não
engana ninguém resolve começar a
escrever no meu próprio podem começar a
criar no simulador sistemas partículas
de prótons e esse foi consegue programar
tempos livres é fazer a algum código e
os 70 mil linhas podem mais tarde então
tinha o meu simulador partículas
aqui vocês vêem ele mexer com um som de
em movimento mas porque seria isto sim é
muito ruim e sim as coisas engraçadas
mas para quem quiser
da mesma forma que ao nível da
computação gráfica
nós não queremos que o animador técnica
nem marca da gota d'água alcança grande
polga deste ano que criamos essas
partículas para o computador crie este
conto tudo está destruído todo
a idéia é aplicar a mesma coisa só nossa
gente hoje em dia se eu tiver a
trabalhar uma grande produção imaginem
um filme que tem uma batalha épica vai
acontecer e vai ver um sound design é um
som de fé é verdade que vai querer criar
um som daquela batalha e tá grande da
sua biblioteca de sons ontem milhares de
sons dos mais diversos tipos vai e vai
ficar uma explosão aqui
outra explosão lhe umas metralhadoras ak
os tipos ali uns gritos ele exclusão que
agora só aqui passar trinta segundos
mais olha ali e vai fazer tudo isso e
foi uma grande produção em casa e aí que
as de tempo provavelmente o salão design
pode passar se calhar uma semana é
trabalhar em tudo isto e talvez juntar a
2011 em simultâneo para criarmos uma
batalha épica com milhares de pela
equipe a lutar entre si a vantagem do
software é que eu posso revelar no
software e dizer eu quero criar 10 mil
sons sai wilson sons espalhados por um
quilômetro quadrado será na biblioteca
de sons pescara 300 sons de guerra que
eu tenho lá para servir como base para a
minha simulação e o software criar então
toda essa batalha não conseguem mas com
100 mil com 10 mil e desta forma ter
algo muito mais realista muito mais
orgânico e é muito menos tempo e com tal
poder criar por exemplo sons como é uma
cilada no século 21
o mais velho de partir o som do batalhão
aéreo na segunda guerra mundial
tudo isso de uma forma muito mais rápida
e muito mais eficiente mas com - qual é
que é prioridade
este software essencialmente embora se
possa ser utilizado em pequenas
produções
a grande maioria delas é utilizada você
poderá ser utilizado em grandes cenas
épicas em grandes filmes é mas qual é
que é privado em um estudo do douro eo
tejo e volta de uma superprodução e
utilizar um software criado um país
assim longínquo do indivíduo mora numa
cidade com ea seu lado nenhum tomemos
aprovada é muito muito mais
mas eu acho que às vezes na vida nós
temos que ter um carro em géneros
convencidos pelo ponto de vista de achar
que isso nós fizemos algo é que nós
queremos fazer é brown ainda vai dar
valor e que tudo será utilizada o fruto
do nosso trabalho e assim foi e continua
a trabalhar independentemente de saber
ser visto os interessados só uma vez
algum estúdio com a cabeça na parede que
lembra que apesar o software e acredito
aí continuei trabalhando há cerca de
animais mais coisa menos coisa é haver
uma conferência em los angeles numa
ofensiva algo em que eu ia participar da
e algumas semanas antes de ir a
conferências resolvi mandar meio de
emails para estudos downloads pessoas
que não conhecia de lado nenhum
garantidamente não conhecia me lado
nenhum e na prática continue maior era
eu trabalhar nesta área é uma tecnologia
pode ser particularmente interessante
grandes produções e de que algumas
semanas votadas nas crianças estiverem
interessados em saber mais do que
qualquer coisa
eu tive a sorte de rapidamente ter tido
algumas respostas
um dos primeiros estúdios que respondeu
foi o carro alcança salvar a empresa de
som criado por george lucas aquando da
guerra das estrelas hoje provavelmente
hoje em dia é o maior estudo de pós
produção áudio para cinema e convidou a
integrar uma palestra é as instalações
deus nos cavalcante que ficam os
elementos a norte de san francisco e nos
meses seguintes
acabei por dar palestras nos vários
estudos ou liuzzi o universo ou
underground paramount pictures sony
fox fixar o painel studios em londres
entre entrou com podem imaginar que
alguém que adora cinema
irei estes sítios conhecer os bastidores
dos estúdios conhecer algumas pessoas
algumas lendas que eu já conhecia de ver
o making off que gente croma ver e é
fantástico como por exemplo criou os
sons da guerra das estrelas
ou então o marido mangini que é daquelas
pessoas que é tem dois minutos nos faz
sentir como se conhecesse a vida toda
pra se ter uma idéia em um parque onde
ganhou o oscar este ano do confirmado
max eu mandei um e mail a dizer parabéns
pelo acho que devo responder mas eu tava
todo mundo gostava dele e e o fantástico
e nós estamos sempre à espera de óleo na
comunidade muito chato sempre estrelas
daquelas coisas todas
e sim aqueles nós em que vemos que não é
tão aberta enquanto isso por exemplo só
entrar no estúdio quanto ao passaporte
ter todos os hospitais
o nome está na lista de pessoas
autorizadas essas coisas todas
na realidade vamos encontrar pessoas
pessoas extremamente fantásticas fora de
série muito simpáticas e que não há
porque querem saber mais sobre o nosso
trabalho e é algo verdadeiramente é
fantástico ver que não é é um grande e
qualquer que nunca ouvi falar é e isto é
fantástico
hoje em dia o software está a ser
testado
aí todos este estudo já começaram a sair
alguns filmes é um dos últimos filmes a
utilizar para ser lançado contra o
software foi precisamente o batom
universo permanente
além disso ou outros filmes softwares
jogos para terminar o trecho que nas
notas que
o importante é a primeira nota e usem as
nossas paixões junta e os óbvios que o
vosso lado profissional utiliza em vossa
paixão que é um combustível fantástico
para o nosso trabalho é a segunda em
pouco tempo a estrela estrela sonhar
alto
acreditem não tenho medo de nada como
uma vida sem sonhos de uma vida um pouco
sem sal e em seu lugar trabalhem foi
xingada aos vossos sonhos tudo os sonhos
dependem essencialmente vocês trabalhem
sim a má notícia é preciso trabalhar
muito realizar os sonhos das boas
notícias é que os sonhos pena pode ser
vista em vários fatores mas acima de
tudo o fator número é o vosso trabalho
se você trabalha trabalha para realizar
os meus sonhos garantidamente ou seja
bom é ter boas possibilidades de lá
chegar
por isso ajudando estas três coisas só
se juntará às nossas paixões os vossos
sonhos e vosso trabalho tudo junto não
só vou poder dar o melhor pra você tem
palavra
mas para além disso o conselho muito
mais feliz obrigado
[Aplausos]